[MUSIC PLAYING]
FILIP: Hello, everyone, and
welcome to the next episode
of "Flutter Boring Show."
I'm here with Andrew.
Hi, Andrew.
ANDREW: Hey, everybody.
FILIP: Today, we'll talk about
how to make Flutter better
by the magic of bug reports.
ANDREW: Yeah, the
key to progress.
FILIP: So this is
actually something
that Eric, the manager of
Flutter, asked us to do.
Actually, he just
asked, did you ever
show in the "Flutter Boring
Show" how to file a bug?
And I realized we didn't, and we
hit a bug last time, actually.
But we figure, when we
were talking about slivers,
in that case, and when
we found that bug,
we didn't just want
to stop doing slivers
and start filing bugs.
So we just postponed it, and
then I filed the bug later.
But I think it's a really good
thing to talk about, right?
Because you do
make Flutter better
just by giving feedback
to the team and all that.
ANDREW: Yeah, I heard
something interesting
that Eric said just sort
of off-hand the other day.
He was like, software doesn't
work until people use it.
It's important to the
success of Flutter
that people use it, and then
let us know how it's working.
These bugs can often influence
not only quality but features.
People submit feature
requests, too.
They're very important
for the engineering team.
FILIP: We both go to events
and talk to developers.
And sometimes you
hear things that
should definitely be filed
as a bug and are not,
just because people--
I'm not sure if it's going to
be worth it and so on and so
forth.
It's going to be worth it.
We promise.
ANDREW: Yes.
People are listening.
FILIP: Yes.
That is to say, don't
be afraid to file bugs.
Sometimes you don't have the
time to really go deep into it.
It's better to have a bug
that is not completely ideal,
but it's there, so the
team knows about it,
other than to have
no bug at all.
Actually, I think you told
me that recently, I think,
Ian was able to
kind of triangulate
an issue from, like,
three incomplete bugs.
But because they
were there, even
though they weren't perfect,
they led them to fix an issue.
OK, so that's the theory.
Obviously, search first.
There's many bugs
that are there.
We might actually
even show it later.
This episode is a how to
file a good bug for Flutter.
I hear that Andrew
has hit a bug.
ANDREW: I recently
ran into a bug.
On my laptop here, I'm working
on Veggie Seasons, which
is a sample app up right now
at our sample repo, which
is flutter slash samples.
And we're doing some work on it.
We got our shots of
vegetables from the studio.
We have some people here who are
photographers and actually took
pictures of vegetables
just for the sample.
Thank you again to the retails.
Those people are awesome.
So it's a sample of
our Cupertino widgets,
which implement
the Cupertino spec.
And while we were
working on search--
so up here, I have
a search thing.
If I just wanted to see
asparagus, I can type that in.
If I keep going here,
I can put in some text
and filter them all out.
This is using a
Cupertino text field.
And I noticed, you can
go in and select text.
And I wanted to see
how that would work,
and I ran into this.
So it's a little thing.
It's not little pop-up tool
tips for cut, copy, and taste,
is it?
Paste.
Must be paste.
They aren't respecting the
safe area as they should.
And so this is something
that the engineers working
on Cupertino definitely
want to know about.
This is something that must
have been a gap in the test
or something like that.
So this is what
we should report,
so they can know that
it's an issue and fix it.
FILIP: OK, so yeah, let's do it.
I'll just be talking along.
But all of the work
will be done by Andrew.
It goes to GitHub.com
slash Flutter for issues.
ANDREW: Yes, so Cupertino
is part of Flutter,
the SDK itself.
That's one of the packages
that comes with it built in.
And so most of the
issues, by the way,
are managed through
Flutter slash Flutter.
Some of the things have
their own little bits,
like the intelligent plugin
has its own issue tracker
and stuff like that.
But our samples
repo, for example,
doesn't have its
own issue tracker.
We actually ask people to file
them at Flutter slash Flutter.
So let's come in here.
And first, let's see if there's
an outstanding bug, which
I have actually not-- this
could be a very short episode.
I actually haven't checked this.
Let's see what we got.
FILIP: OK, we're scrolling.
Yeah, I don't think it's there.
ANDREW: OK, thank you.
FILIP: Good.
ANDREW: It would have
been a very short episode
if I hadn't checked that.
So first thing, obviously,
check to see if somebody's
filed a bug already.
You can come in, and you can add
your bug report to an existing
one and say, hey, I ran
into this with this code.
Here's my Flutter
Doctor outputs,
so you know what version I'm
using and things like that.
That's one thing.
FILIP: Also, tips
for finding bugs
is, obviously, error
messages, especially the part
which is the same
whatever you use.
Some people will try
to search for things
that include the path in their
app, which obviously won't
find what you are looking for.
But for example, if we
put in a text field,
it's the same in every project.
So that's helpful.
And also, if you just
see a bug, and you
don't have anything to add--
can you open one of the bugs--
it's helpful to take
the first of the issues
here and add a reaction
to it with a thumbs up.
We actually look at this.
And the issues with
the most thumbs
up will kind of
have more attention.
ANDREW: The engineering
team, they can sort by that.
Those are the ones that
people care about the most.
They're going to get a
little bit more attention.
FILIP: Yeah, so whenever you
feel the need to say something
like plus-one, or me, too,
or I see this as well,
or what's happening,
just do a thumbs up,
and it's going to be better.
ANDREW: Yeah, especially
for feature requests.
You see a feature
request for like,
oh, I wish there was
a widget to do this,
or I wish this widget could
do this, something like that.
If somebody has already posted
that, and you come in here
and it already exists,
definitely go in and be like,
yeah, me, too.
That would help my app.
I need that use case
covered as well.
But we don't have
an issue, so we
got to go over to yonder
new issue button over here.
FILIP: And there's
three things--
difficulty installing.
That's not it.
I have a problem
with my Flutter app,
or I want help writing my app.
Most of the time,
you will probably
click the button in the middle.
ANDREW: In the middle one, yeah.
So that's what we're having.
A widget is buggy,
or it looks wrong.
That's definitely
else right now.
And so some of this
is filled out for us.
FILIP: Please, don't
ignore the comments here.
The comments tell you
exactly what to do.
Let's go through
them one by one.
So if you're looking
for support that we did,
steps to reproduce.
So I think any good bug has a
repo case or something similar.
So in our case, the repo
case is actually pretty--
ANDREW: We have a guide for this
people could check out, too.
FILIP: Oh, wow.
Yeah, I didn't know.
ANDREW: [INAUDIBLE] must
have put this together.
So we also have a guide.
We have video form
and guide form.
A lot of this, I
think, is covered
in the comments within the bug
report tool itself in GitHub.
But if you would like a
little more information--
FILIP: The crash log--
Nice.
ANDREW: So this
is there as well.
Now I've completely derailed
your train of thought
that you were on.
I'm sorry.
FILIP: No, this is good.
So yeah, I was like, is this
a completely necessary video?
But no.
So steps to reproduce--
in our case,
what's the steps to reproduce?
ANDREW: So that's
a good question.
This isn't the biggest
app in the world,
but this app has some structure
to it and things like that.
And so I can say, like, I used
a Cupertino text field that
was near the top of the screen.
And I can detail those steps.
It might also potentially
be a good idea
to try and narrow
down this use case
and actually get code to
reproduce it in the bug report.
Do you want to try that real
quick and see what we do?
FILIP: We could try that.
To be clear, I think,
in this particular case,
this might not be
needed, unless someone
wants to write a test case,
which it would be very helpful,
I guess.
So maybe, yeah.
Maybe just to be super good
citizens, we can try that.
ANDREW: I wonder
if we could just
take this widget out and just
use it on its own temporarily.
So let's go into main here.
Let's see if I can get this
to paste and copy here.
FILIP: Oh, yeah.
ANDREW: Let me come do that.
I can just say, run app.
And I'll give it Cupertino apps.
This is a Cupertino widget.
I definitely need that.
Then I could just do home--
FILIP: As the search for?
ANDREW: Yeah, let's try that
and just see what happens.
This may just completely
crash and burn.
And first, I'll have to restart,
which I recently found out
there is a key command for--
Command-Shift and Backslash.
FILIP: Yep.
I'm not sure if
that's on every--
ANDREW: So that puts me in the
middle, but I still got it.
FILIP: Yeah, OK, cool.
So yeah, I think we can just--
ANDREW: Let me see if I
can just nudge this up
to the top real quick.
How am I going to do that?
I could do a medium-sized
box, something like that.
FILIP: The easy way
would be column with one
of those things expanded.
ANDREW: There you go.
FILIP: Coulombs.
ANDREW: I can't
even spell columns.
Columbs-- we're measuring
electrons today.
Yes, let's do children, and
that's an array, actually.
Let's do another.
I can expand it down here.
Can I just do
expand it like that,
or does it need a [INAUDIBLE]?
FILIP: Oh, interesting.
ANDREW: Finding new use cases.
Everyone's favorite
default child--
container.
Since I'm in run app itself--
helps to get the
right key command.
There we go.
FILIP: That might be
a little too wide.
ANDREW: That might be too wide.
Here.
We'll put a little sized box in.
FILIP: Well, actually, you
could put it into safe area
just to show that the whole
thing, it is in a safe area.
ANDREW: That's a good point.
FILIP: I mean, the column would
be in the safe area, right?
Oh, I'm sorry.
I didn't realize that you
already had the size box.
ANDREW: No, it's OK.
I'll restart.
Let's see if I can
still reproduce this.
Cool.
So now, we have our
significantly smaller--
FILIP: Yeah, can
you get rid of that,
by the way, the
preferred orientation?
ANDREW: Then we'll
definitely have
to restart this one more time.
Cool.
And there it is.
OK, this isn't bad.
This is still, like,
80 lines of code.
But somebody can
take this one file,
and throw it into an
empty Flutter project
and very quickly
reproduce this bug.
We're talking to mostly
software engineers here.
Everybody knows
how much that helps
find the root cause of a problem
when there's no magic involved.
So let's take this, then.
Actually, let's just go
back to our bug screen
and see what we can do.
This is just a comment, right?
So we can probably
take that out now.
So steps to reproduce--
well, title.
FILIP: Title-- you could
leave it as the last thing.
Actually, it helps, because it
might help you find other bugs.
ANDREW: Which apparently is
a new feature from GitHub.
What do we call them, tool tips?
FILIP: Yeah.
Safe area, OK, yes.
ANDREW: There we go.
And so that's our title.
So steps to reproduce
is next, so we
can put in a brief description.
FILIP: You brief description
was basically in the title,
but yeah.
ANDREW: Look at that.
So I have this code.
I'll move steps to reproduce
from there, because that's
where titles go--
at the top of things.
Now, we can paste our code in.
And then I can pull out--
some of these
imports aren't used,
so just the first and the last.
Shoot, I'm referencing
colors in here.
FILIP: Is it fine?
ANDREW: It's probably fine.
FILIP: I mean, you
don't need this,
right, the Veggie Seasons think
they won't have access to--
ANDREW: Yeah, that is the
thing that they wouldn't.
So this can come out.
FILIP: That's another one.
ANDREW: This is Dart
code, by the way.
FILIP: Oh, you had
the color there.
ANDREW: That's what
I was thinking.
So if I comment
this out, then I'm
stuck with some colors
that don't work.
But I can do this real quick,
like, a background gray.
I can just pull
these out real quick.
FILIP: Yeah, OK.
So yeah, ideally,
you want as few lines
as possible, obviously.
But you don't need to
stress it, I guess.
Yeah, nice.
ANDREW: There's an
active blue right here.
Interesting all these
things that the iOS does.
And our audience are like,
obviously those exist.
I'll make this one black.
FILIP: OK, let's try it.
ANDREW: Yeah, I'm
actually making sure
that it still works.
That's probably a good idea.
So do a hard restart.
Yeah.
Thank God, it didn't work.
FILIP: So you don't
need all that basically.
ANDREW: Yeah, we'll go
ahead and paste this in.
There we go.
FILIP: So yeah, the
three double vectors,
I think, we don't
need to explain.
ANDREW: Although those putting
the dart at the end of it--
I don't know if that's
required or not.
I always do it--
FILIP: Yeah, it'd be like--
ANDREW: --to be like a
little handling-- by the way,
this is Dart code.
FILIP: Yes, yeah, so yeah.
ANDREW: So we don't need this.
We don't need any
of that anymore.
FILIP: Cool.
ANDREW: Don't need any of
this commented out code.
There we go.
FILIP: Cool.
ANDREW: So now I've got
something that's all in one,
so it's completely
self-contained.
And one of the
engineers can just
cut and paste it into a
project, see immediately
what I'm talking about.
FILIP: Right.
So we have that.
Now, the reason why they're
asking us for step by step is
often because-- especially
if you have an error,
they want to know
what to do, but--
yes, exactly.
ANDREW: Now we have to actually
have some random characters.
Highlight it.
Helps to spell it correctly.
Although that's
optional sometimes.
And then what do we do?
So we-- can I clear this?
So we came in here,
we tapped on--
we added a bunch of characters.
We double tapped,
and then that's it.
FILIP: That's it, OK.
And so at this point, especially
since this is a visual bug,
really, it's really helpful to
include a screenshot, which--
ANDREW: Oh, yeah!
FILIP: --you can do.
So yeah, I mean, because
as soon as someone
who does Cupertino widgets
sees that screenshot,
he will immediately
know what's going on.
ANDREW: I should
mention I'm running
this on a device with a notch.
FILIP: Ooh, yeah.
Nice.
ANDREW: What am I actually
using, just so I know?
FILIP: iPhone X?
ANDREW: This is a XS Max.
FILIP: Ooh!
Is it slower?
ANDREW: 10S Max?
Is that how you pronounce--
FILIP: I don't know.
ANDREW: Because it was the
IPhone 10 instead the iPhone X,
even though I called it the
X for, like, three months.
FILIP: Yeah, I just
say X and that's it.
OK, so-- doo, doo, doo.
ANDREW: So we got that.
And you were just
talking about--
FILIP: Screenshots.
ANDREW: Taking a picture, OK.
FILIP: Yes, so
make a screenshot.
On a Mac, that's pretty easy.
ANDREW: So we can
do-- what is up with--
FILIP: Command-Shift-4 and
then Space is my favorite.
ANDREW: What's the one
where you get to connect--
you, like, draw the box
that you're cutting out.
FILIP: That's Command-Shift-4.
Command-Shift-4, yeah.
But then if you do Space
now, just hover over it
and do [CLICKS TONGUE].
ANDREW: Oh, and does that make--
FILIP: That will give you like a
screenshot of that window only.
ANDREW: Does it go
to the file system?
FILIP: It goes to
the desktop for me.
ANDREW: So I think one of
the other things, just to--
I think it's easier to
do from my keyboard.
I think it's this one?
So Control-Shift-Command-4
will do it to the clipboard.
FILIP: Oh!
ANDREW: And so we can
come in here and do this.
FILIP: I didn't know that.
ANDREW: And I think I can
come in and just go like that.
FILIP: That's cool.
ANDREW: I can't remember
who told me that.
FILIP: Preview.
ANDREW: So we've got
our nicely formatted--
FILIP: Yeah, nice.
ANDREW: My, that's huge.
FILIP: That's
normal, that's fine.
ANDREW: OK.
[LAUGHTER]
It's a very large bug.
OK, so let's go back
into our Writes thing.
FILIP: OK, yeah, and I
think you're basically done.
I mean, if this was an error
again, we could do-- actually,
let's use--
ANDREW: Let's do Flutter
doctor real quick.
FILIP: Yeah.
ANDREW: Do you want to do that?
Always a good idea
to include this,
I feel, even if
they don't need it.
FILIP: Yes.
ANDREW: Nobody's ever sad
to see Flutter doctor.
FILIP: I think dash v is
what they're asking for,
just because it
gives you more info.
ANDREW: We can do that too.
FILIP: Is it--
ANDREW: Like that?
FILIP: Yeah, I think so.
Yeah, OK, yeah.
ANDREW: Bam!
FILIP: All the
checkmarks, all good.
Yeah, OK, so that's one.
And I also want to
just show how to do
Flutter run verbose from an
ID, which is not completely
like some--
ANDREW: OK, yeah.
FILIP: Yeah, yeah.
So you have it there?
I mean, Flutter
actually is there?
So yeah, like, what
I would normally do
is just open a terminal and just
run Flutter around dash dash
verbose, right?
But if you don't
like terminals--
and I don't blame you--
you just go to the run
configuration-- or debug
configuration actually.
Which is I think over
here in the main like--
ANDREW: Oh, you mean like in
here, in the configurations.
FILIP: Yeah, add configuration.
And just add additional
arguments dash dash verbose.
I think that's
what it is, right?
ANDREW: Like that?
FILIP: Can you go
back to the Get Help?
Yeah, Flutter run verbose, yes.
I think that's what it does.
And now you always run verbose.
But if you do like--
ANDREW: So I'd have to restart
this at this point, right?
FILIP: Yeah, yeah.
ANDREW: We completely
restart the process.
FILIP: See, and
you get all this.
So I still recommend terminal.
But if you prefer
this, that's great.
And you can just like--
ANDREW: That is indeed verbose.
FILIP: It is very
verbose, correct.
[LAUGHTER]
So yeah, I think--
is there something
else that they are--
ANDREW: So let's go back
in-- so, we got to paste in--
FILIP: Yeah, I don't think in
this particular case anybody
is actually interested in locks.
ANDREW: Yeah, not for the--
I don't think so.
FILIP: Yeah.
ANDREW: But I can always
put Flutter doctor
so everybody knows what
version of the SDK I'm using.
FILIP: Yes, that's true.
Oh, and Flutter analyze as well.
So I think that-- yeah.
Just to follow what they
want, the Flutter doctor
is at the end.
ANDREW: Oh!
I messed up the--
FILIP: Yeah, it's here.
ANDREW: OK.
Let me just back all this up.
FILIP: Yeah.
ANDREW: I guess I'll take this
fake headline that I made out.
FILIP: Yeah.
That's where-- OK.
ANDREW: There we go.
Following the
instructions for the web.
I don't think there's
anything here.
FILIP: Yeah, no.
ANDREW: Ooh!
Oh, because we just
pasted all the code in.
FILIP: Right.
ANDREW: And I'm in the middle
of implementing something
completely [INAUDIBLE].
FILIP: Yeah, let's not.
Just pretend there's nothing.
ANDREW: Yeah, let's do that.
It is normally a good idea.
FILIP: Yes.
ANDREW: And to be honest,
you should always have--
you should always use analyzer.
Where's my FA alias
that I use all the time?
It looks for Dart files
and then pipes them
into Flutter format, and then
Flutter Analyze after that.
FILIP: Ooh, I'm not familiar.
What do you mean?
ANDREW: Yeah, what is--
FILIP: Oh, Flutter--
ANDREW: FA, this one.
FILIP: Flutter format
and Flutter analyze.
ANDREW: I use this all the time.
FILIP: Oh!
I like that, that you
have an alias for that.
ANDREW: So it looks
for all the Dart files,
pipes them in the Flutter
format using xargs,
and then after that--
so they're all
formatted in place.
And then after that, it
runs Flutter analyze.
That's my last thing before
I try to commit code,
I run that alias.
FILIP: Do you have
Dart installed?
Because what I do--
ANDREW: I installed Dart.
I have the Dart SDK that
Flutter installs in its cache.
FILIP: Oh, OK, so you don't--
yeah, because if at home,
you have Dart installed, you
just do Dart format, dot.
And it will just go
through the whole directory
and will analyze and format
everything, which is cool.
It's really cool.
Anyway, but we're
on attention here.
So I think we have that.
So just some things to realize.
So we did add a repo case.
We did follow the instructions
that they gave us.
One thing that actually
the Flutter community
is really good at--
but in general in open
source sometimes--
it's not that great is
the lack of emotions.
Sometimes bug reports can have a
little bit of how could this be
and all this.
So thank you, Flutter
community, for being awesome.
And keep doing this.
There is--
ANDREW: Should I go ahead
and submit this, by the way?
FILIP: I'm just going
through a checklist here.
So there is the
expected behavior,
which we did not include.
In this case, I think it's all--
again, it's sort of obvious.
But there is a reason why
people ask for it in bugs.
Because sometimes it's
like, oh, this doesn't work.
And you as a developer or
the developer of that tool
will be like, OK, so what did
you expect to happen, right?
So its expected
behavior is great.
ANDREW: Yeah, because
every once in a while,
you run into
something that works,
but it doesn't work
in the way that you
were intending to use it.
FILIP: Yeah.
ANDREW: And if you just
change up how you're using it,
it's fine.
FILIP: Yeah.
ANDREW: And sometimes that's
OK, and sometimes it's--
I haven't seen this come
up in the case of Flutter--
poor API design in other
things that I've seen before.
Like, suddenly you
see bugs where just
the API was designed
in such a way
that nobody really understands
how to use it properly.
FILIP: Right.
ANDREW: And so that
is a bug with the API.
FILIP: Yes, yes.
So more content is almost
always better than less.
So if you're
undersized, just add it.
Screenshots, videos, we
did, so that's great.
Often, if you're
an engineer, you
will immediately jump to
solutions and diagnosis.
And what works best always
impacts just the symptoms,
and then you can
add your diagnosis.
But sometimes-- I do this a lot.
I'm like, I think this
should be fixed by X.
ANDREW: [INAUDIBLE]
FILIP: Yeah, yeah, and
someone is like, ugh, no.
So that's great.
And I really like the
mongoose vs. antelope--
what do you call
it, like metaphor?
You don't know it?
ANDREW: No.
FILIP: So apparently--
I don't know where I read it.
But basically-- and I
do this all the time.
If I find a bug, I
act as a mongoose.
Like, I see something,
and immediately I
try to fix it in
many different ways.
I Flutter clean everything
and do all these things.
So I'm like a mongoose
that's attacked, right?
And the antelope-- what
it does if it's attacked,
or like if there is some
trouble, it freezes.
So you should be an antelope.
Like if something--
ANDREW: Like freezes or stops?
FILIP: OK, don't touch anything.
Sometimes it's really helpful to
have your computer in the state
where it happened.
ANDREW: Ah, yeah.
FILIP: Because-- A,
you could basically
erase some of the stuff that the
implementer then needs to see.
And sometimes actually
by trying to fix the bug
you will have another thing that
kind of counteracts the bug.
But it actually doesn't
help, because either you
don't report it then, or it's
just there's two levels of bugs
that need to be unrolled.
So if something
doesn't work, kind of
assume that this is
a bug with Flutter
and report it before
trying to figure out stuff.
OK, so that's great.
Let's submit, I think.
If you are happy, I'm happy.
ANDREW: And we should talk
about what happens to a bug
after this.
But real quick before
we move on, I also--
this has come up
a couple of times
when I've talked to
people just randomly
at talks and things like that.
There are people who
feel reluctant to file
a bug because they just assume
it's their fault somehow.
FILIP: Yeah, yeah.
ANDREW: And I should make
clear, the engineering team--
they really want bug
reports, because it
helps them make the SDK
better, makes Flutter better
for everybody.
But also, Flutter-- I mean,
everybody on Flutter--
and I've seen in the
community for the most part--
they're not jerks.
Like I've filed bad bug reports
before that were my fault.
I've posted emails
to the Google group
before where it was
clearly like I'm
the only one in the room that
doesn't understand what's
going on.
That's happened to me.
And people were very patient
and very nice about it.
No one is going to jump on
your bug report and be like,
oh, you're stupid, you should
have just done this and this,
and you would have worked
around this problem.
That is not going
to happen to anybody
that submits a bug report.
So if you run into something--
and especially if you take the
steps to isolate it and give
a good bug report, people
will react with appreciation,
even if it ends up not being
a problem with the SDK itself.
They're still going to be
glad that you came to them.
So don't be afraid to file one.
FILIP: Yeah, cool.
So we have our bug.
Let see what other
things we have in GitHub
that people might
like to look at.
ANDREW: Yeah, sure.
FILIP: So that's Issues, there's
Code, obviously, Pull Requests,
Projects-- what's projects?
ANDREW: Oh, yeah.
So Projects-- I think we talked
about a little of this before.
This came up during
the Ask Flutter
part of the Q&A a little bit.
But you know, Flutter
is open source.
It's also developed in the
open for the most part.
Like almost everything
that's going on with Flutter,
you can find people
working on GitHub.
And that includes project
planning for a lot of stuff.
So Cupertino Table View
right now is being worked on.
That's another Cupertino
widget that's coming along.
And so you can come
in here and say, OK, I
want to know what's the progress
of this, and here it is.
These are the issues
where the team
is tracking what's going on.
So it looks like there are a
few widget work features that
are still being done over here
in edit mode, some reordering
stuff.
He's got some other tasks--
this looks like Matt's the one
working on it--
about getting into
the Flutter gallery
so people can see it there,
and it's a good way to test it.
But if you're ever curious
what people are working on
or anything like that, you can
come into this projects page
and get a good handle on it.
FILIP: Yeah, I like--
ANDREW: Hierarchy is up here.
FILIP: Yeah, I like how if
you just look at issues--
right, like you have a bunch
of issues that are just
unstructured, this
is the structured way
of how the Flutter team
sees the work ahead.
So I think that's
really cool to look at.
ANDREW: Yeah, and so this
looks like some tooling stuff
that Greg's working on.
Some of these like
speed up pub get
in bots is just like
testing framework
stuff that the average person--
I never have to think about
that you, because Greg does it.
But it's still there.
You can still come in and--
(LAUGHING) even
individual engineers
just have their
little task list.
Like this is [? Jiao's ?] stuff.
He's working on a bunch of
Cupertino things, and so on.
FILIP: Cool, so
that's projects here.
That, I think, is a
good segue to Dart lang.
ANDREW: Oh yeah.
FILIP: So we have
Flutter, GitHub, Repo,
which is about Flutter.
But obviously, Flutter is a big
customer of Dart, and of all--
you write Dart.
And so many of the things that
might be either buggy, or you
want some features added are
actually Dart feature and not
Flutter features.
So if you go to the Dart lang--
ANDREW: Oh, that's right!
I was looking at
the language funnel.
FILIP: Yeah, the
language funnel.
So in general, just
the Dart lang org
is where the SDK lives,
where all the things like,
for example, Dart code
formatting, that start
style, the actual test
that Flutter is building
upon with their test framework.
So all this is
there, and you can
definitely-- that
team is as open as far
in terms of features.
But they also have
in their language,
which is where they are
designing the Dart language.
They have projects there.
So these are all markdown files.
But if you go to
projects, you will
see what they are looking at.
ANDREW: The funnel.
FILIP: And it's
called the funnel.
And I like this,
because basically, it
goes from left to right, from
being discussed all the way
to ready for implementation.
And again, it's a
more structured view
of what's coming, and I think--
ANDREW: And so this is like
the being discussed column
over here on the left.
And so this is the stuff that
may be part of Dart some day,
or might not be, you know?
Like multiple return
values, that's
something that-- like
Python has multiple returns
and things like that.
But maybe that fits Dart,
maybe it does not fit Dart.
FILIP: I think a
lot of people will
be interested in the second
column, first thing--
sound non-nullable types
with incremental migration.
ANDREW: Yep.
FILIP: Yeah, so if you want
to be part of spec-ing this,
then jump in.
ANDREW: Yeah, or just--
be one of these thumbs.
FILIP: Yeah, yeah.
ANDREW: You can come
in-- and we were
talking about feature
requests for Flutter.
It certainly
applies to Dart too.
If you see something in here,
you can come in and say like--
even just yes, I vote on this.
This is important to me.
And you can also come in
and comment, and be like,
here's some code
I wrote recently.
And I would love it if it looked
like this instead, something
like that.
FILIP: Yeah, that could
be another episode
of like how to write good
language feature requests.
Anyway, OK, so that's that.
And the last thing we could
talk about is pull requests.
So obviously, there's a lot
of work involved in just
creating a good bug report.
And you're distracting the
audience by reading this.
ANDREW: I know.
I'm so--
FILIP: (LAUGHING) And me.
ANDREW: I can't wait for
spread collections to make it.
FILIP: Yeah.
So if it looks like a good and
easy fix, don't be afraid to,
again, create a PR.
We have a lot of external
contribution in Flutter.
ANDREW: Oh, yeah.
FILIP: So that's cool.
And if you just want to tip your
toes into Flutter development,
as in like the Flutter SDK
development, search for easy
fix.
That's a filter
that the team adds
to things that should be pretty
easy, even for a third party
or for someone who's not super
familiar with the Flutter code
to fix.
So I recommend it.
ANDREW: Yeah, sample code
for popular API docs.
That's definitely something that
somebody can come in and do.
Whereas, I isolate termination
to terminate all isolates--
FILIP: Yeah, well, for
Chinmay it's an easy fix.
ANDREW: Yeah.
FILIP: Anyway, so
yeah, thank you.
I mean, unless you have
other things to add?
ANDREW: No, I'm just--
yeah, you can check to see
if anybody's assigned to it
or working on it.
You can check to see the
comments that people have left
on it and things like that.
And it's a good
way to get started.
FILIP: Yeah.
So the main message, filing
good bugs is a skill.
And don't be afraid to do it.
ANDREW: An important skill.
FILIP: And an important skill.
Thank you.
We'll see you next time.
ANDREW: Yep.
Bye, everybody.
[MUSIC PLAYING]